Hello? Hello. Hello.
Welcome to another episode of revisiting my personal health for your amusement
guys. This is the start of an accidental live stream on Thursday.
In case you missed it two hours and 16 minutes of this could have
been shown much worse. I'm happy to report that.
I was basically just fixing a mic stand, but you cannot imagine the horror.
When later I go out to dinner and I'm just live streaming, this, this text,
what is this live stream? No signal. I say what live stream.
And I get texted from another friend, you know, you're live, right?
I say, uh, no. And immediately panicked because I'm thinking,
okay, what did I do on the stream?
Cause I must have accidentally pressed go live. I'm thinking,
did I accidentally, you know,
reveal my dark secret that I accidentally show my talking fan fiction.
It was a long ride home.
I like to imagine the emotions I was feeling was something like what Mr. Toubin
must've been feeling when he was, uh, suddenly realized he had been live.
Now of course I wasn't doing anything like that,
but I was because of Susan,
Susan and Jeff. If you stream on Twitch,
they're out here trying to catch you. Slipping is what I read.
I started doing some research guys.
Do you realize that streaming live to all your fans
is a one-click. It's a,
all I have to do is press on OBS a little start streaming button here.
I'll put it right here. Start streaming. That's it
to everyone. And that's what happened.
I was adjusting my mic and it just hit go live.
And all of a sudden I'm on live in front of, you know,
tens of thousands of people. I don't know how many people turned in.
Probably probably know.
Now you might be asking yourself what kind of user design experience doesn't
ask. Hey, are you sure you want to go live to your entire audience right now?
That's what you want. I think they would do. I'm pretty quickly.
I came to one conclusion, Hey, I better do something about this.
So I went to the office and got to work and I realized that I was far from the
only person this has happened to. I mean,
apparently this happens to streamers all the time.
There's a whole category on YouTube called accidentally,
went live of all the YouTubers who accidentally go live and embarrass themselves
on camera because it's so easy to go live on
accident. It's happened in Ninja. It's happened to pokey. Maine.
Look at this guy, OMG, Chad. He was asleep,
his cat pressed the button on his stream deck.
And then a bunch of people called him.
But imagine the stop that could have happened at best.
It's embarrassing at worst it's career ending all because of the
terrible design of going live. But my mind fool me once,
shame on Susan, fool me twice, shame on me.
So I was determined to create a, not just for.
Me, but also for streamers everywhere.
I feel like I want to create like a puppy commercial.
Like every day a streamer's life is ruined.
I literally mean to click start streaming by an accidental live stream.
Do you guys remember this guy, dark side, Phil,
this is like the worst thing that can happen to you. Uh,
or people like Jeffrey Toobin on zoom. I mean, you know,
I call it the getting me Tuben you get caught tug in the tube every
day. A streamer's life gets ruined by a me tube in moment. And because of that,
I created this product. I call it the tube switch.
It's a little script.
I wrote an OBS to prevent you from having these embarrassing things happen to
you. Whenever you go live,
it automatically switches to a warning scene of your choosing.
This is the one I created that starts with a news alert of Jeffrey Toobin.
Then it goes into the candid camera intro, uh, with full music.
So you know that you're live
[inaudible]. So if that doesn't already get your attention,
there gets to be this tube and switch counter that automatically starts.
It's a timer of your choosing.
And if you have not clicked off of this scene within OBS,
by the time that it's run down automatically OBS stops
streaming. So it's basically a dead man switch. If you accidentally press it,
if your cat accidentally presses it at five in the morning,
it puts you on some innocuous scene like this.
And then by the time the timer runs down,
it just gets you out of the live stream.
Now I know what you're saying to yourself. Okay, Steven. Cool, cool,
cool program you made, uh, how much does it cost? Good question.
Because you know, as well as I do, as Dan Locke says,
if you're good at something, don't do it for free.
So at first I was thinking to myself, how much should I charge for this?
How much would people like Ninja pokey,
Maine pay to not lose their career from getting me tube?
And it's a good question. How much would you pay for the peace of mind?
So at first I was thinking millions, but then I thought, no, Steven,
you can't do that to the copy's Zillow army. They got you here.
They want better than that. So I said,
maybe I'll bring it down to a hundred K maybe bring it down by 90%.
And still I felt bad. I felt it's a little expensive.
So today limited time
supply. There's only so many of these that can go around.
I am offering this E product,
not at 99% off, not at 99.9% off,
which is a bargain already at a thousand dollars,
but I'm offering it for a hundred percent off
with the purchase of a Twitter follow and a YouTube subscription.
Show those at,
in the link below and you will get this product absolutely free.
Yeah, I know. I know I'm giving, I'm giving it all away.
I'm giving my secrets away. So by now,
because I don't want what happened to me to happen to you.
Don't let Susan catch slipping say yeah.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.